Друзі, всім привіт!
Настав час нашій сімейній автівці проходити технічний огляд.
У Німеччині цим займається сертифікована державою організація – ТЮФ.
Ну що ж, давайте подивимось, чи пройде цей
8-річний "японець" суворий німецький технічний тест.
Станція Тюф, із якою я домовився про техогляд,
розташована в Кельні за 40 кілометрів
від мого будинку. А в мене лише чверть баку…
Друзі, я приїхав заправитися і я приємно вражений.
Ціни на бензин впали щонайменше на 20 євроцентів.
Це наслідок світового падіння цін на нафту.
Бачите, в Німеччині це працює.
Заправив бензин марки Супер 95 Е10.
Його ціна в середині листопада торік була один євро 56 центів за літр.
А в середині січня 2019-го - вже один євро 33 центи за літр.
На одному повному баку "джука" -  економія в 10 євро.
Поїхали далі.
TÜV - абревіатура від Technischer Überwachungsverein
- Об’єднання технічного нагляду.
Членами  об’єднання є підприємства, які вводять
в експлуатацію обладнання, що потребує технічного нагляду.
Створене об’єднання в 1866 році для перевірки тодішніх парових котлів.
Сьогодні ТЮФ перевіряє все: від настільних ламп
до атракціонів у парку розваг. ТЮФ -
зареєстрована торгова марка, яка передусім
асоціюється з техоглядом автомобілів.
Німці так і питають: твоя машина пройшла ТЮФ?
- Ми є міжнародним сервісом тестування. У нас
працюють 20 тисяч людей. Наше кредо - безпека
і нейтральність. Ми перевіряємо автомобілі
міжнародних виробників.
Техогляд "джука" проводитиме тестувальник Торстен Рехтієн.
У техпаспорті зазначено: грудень 2018-го. Це дата,
коли вам знову треба на техогляд.
На номері автомобіля ззаду ліпиться от така плакетка.
Усередині бачимо цифру 18.
Це означає 2018-й рік.
Рік завжди посередині.
А цифри нагорі - це місяць.
Техогляд треба робити раз на два роки.
Якщо прострочити дату техогляду на два місяці, штраф - 15 євро.
Якщо на понад вісім місяців, штраф - 75 євро і
занесення одного штрафного пункту до картотеки водія у Фленсбурзі.
Вісім таких пунктів – і заберуть права. Однак
головне, що після прострочення дати техогляду
припиняється дія страхування машини.
Після звірення дати техогляду - перевірка гальм.
На ножних гальмах допускається послаблення до 25%,
на ручнику падіння гальмівної сили допускається до 50%.
"Ніссан" вклався із запасом у ці показники.
Далі - візуальна перевірка ізольованості контактів акумулятора,
відсутності підтікань робочих рідин та звірення
номера кузова автомобіля з номером у техпаспорті.
Номер кузова авто на рамі збігається з номером у техпаспорті.
Це означає, що мені можна продовжувати.
А не збігся б, тоді б я викликав поліцію. Ги-ги-ги
Техогляд автомобілів у Німеччині запровадили в 1951 році.
Із 2010 року його обов'язковою складовою є
дослідження рівня шкідливих викидів транспортного засобу.
Торстен вкладає у вихлопну трубу датчик і надягає
на неї прилад, який всмоктує вихлопи. Тепер треба
з'єднати автівку з комп'ютером.
Цей штекер - для зняття "бортових" даних машини.
А цей прилад, якщо все правильно працюватиме,
передаватиме інформацю по Bluetooth на комп'ютер.
Після встановлення зв'язку з комп'ютером
тестувальник не має жодного впливу на перебіг техогляду.
Він лише виконує вказівки комп'ютерної програми.
Тестувальник не може втрутитися і змінити жоден із показників.
Я маю тримати потрібну кількість обертів.
Показники мають залишатися в зеленому діапазоні.
Після прогазовування з різною кількістю обертів
система дає "добро" на продовження огляду.
Перевірку рівня викидів машина пройшла!
Ніссан "джук" підтвердив свій рівень викидів Євро 5.
Однак у Німеччині, де діють жорсті закони захисту довкілля,
ТЮФ щодо викидів суворий не для всіх. Є винятки.
Дорогами Німеччини їздить понад мільйон автораритетів.
Такі автомобілі німці називають англійським словом "олдтаймер".
Звичайно, ТЮФ не вимагатиме від такого драндулетика викидів СО2 на рівні Євро5.
Однак звання "олдтаймер" ще треба заслужити.
У Німеччині 477 тисяч машин мають номерні знаки
серії "Н" –це автівки, які є історично цінними.
Далі їдемо на стенд перевірки світла.
За дзеркалами тестувальник перевіряє,
чи працюють усі лампи, а також перевіряє систему
регулювання висоти світла. Якби фари зараз
не піднялися, машина б не пройшла тест і я б
отримав рекомендацію від ТЮФ протягом місяця
ліквідувати ці несправності і з'явитися на новий техогляд.
Тепер - перевірка кута падіння світла на спеціальному приладі.
Якщо зазирнути всередину, то бачимо, як має бути
налаштоване світло. Якби ця лінія була зависоко, це
означало б, що світло налаштоване занизько.
А якби лінія була ось так - це ще гірше, бо світло
було б зависоко і сліпило б зустрічні автівки.
Але тут усе в порядку. Подивимося,
що у нас з іншою фарою.
Тут також усе бездоганно.
Далі Торстен піднімає автівку.
Тестувальник починає обмацувати нижню частину машини
голими руками і підсвічує темні місця ліхтариком.
Торстен перевірив стан гальмівних колодок і дисків,
амортизатори, зношеність профілю шин.
Тут зовнішня кришка бензобаку. А тут можна
побачити з'єднання з паливним баком. Я перевіряю,
чи нічого тут не протікає,
чи немає сильного запаху бензину.
Я все оглянув.
Піднімаємо машину ще вище.
Тепер тестувальнику зручно оглянути стан порогів автівки знизу.
Спереду дивиться, чи немає протікань мастила
під двигуном та коробкою передач. Далі
натиском кнопки на підйомнику Торстен активує
систему, яка крутить колеса по вісі ліворуч-праворуч,
а потім розхитує автомобіль.
Це дозволяє Торстену побачити ймовірні дефекти ходової частини.
Далі - перевірка вихлопної системи на корозію
і надійність кріплення. Також тестувальник оглядає
усі патрубки.  Видно, що тестувальник задоволений і у нього нема нарікань.
Поставлю Торстену провокаційне запитання.
Як він вважає, які машини кращі: японські чи німецькі?
Ну, так однозначно неможливо відповісти.
Звичайно, цей автомобіль дешевший, ніж скажімо,
подібний від німецького виробника.
У січні цій машині вісім років. Це хороша машина,
добротна і ощадна в експлуатації, чи не так?
Далі - печатка в техпаспорт і роздруківка результатів
проходження техогляду з конкретними показниками
плюс оплата за техогляд - 106 євро 40 центів.
Плакетка про техогляд у 2020 році – синя.
Здеру стару наліпку.
Існують різні типи несправностей. Є незначні
несправності, з якими далі можна їздити, однак
із часом їх треба усунути. Але якщо є значні вади,
машина мусить негайно їхати на ремонт.
Однак сьогодні - навіть без дрібних несправностей.
У Німеччині існує єдиний каталог, де перелічено
близько 2,5 тисяч видів несправностей.
350 із них - незначні, і власник авто отримає плакетку-наліпку,
якщо запевнить, що незабаром їх усуне.
Ще 150 - це критичні несправності, через які авто
не має права навіть покинути майданчик техогляду самостійно.
Решта - значні несправності, які не дають права
пройти техогляд і які спершу доводеться усунути.
Техогляд від ТЮФ перевіряє насамперед,
чи відповідає авто вимогам безпеки дорожнього руху і захисту довкілля.
Це не є ретельною діагностикою окремих деталей та електроніки.
Не можу не розповісти вам про невеличку пригоду по дорозі назад.
На автобані з Кельна в Бонн через ремонт дороги
навігатор підказав мені об'їзний шлях, і я поїхав
через маленькі містечка. І тут трапилося небачене!
А тепер - наша рубрика "Не все в Німеччині ідеально".
Я з'їхав з траси. Дивіться, яка тут дорога.
Це найгірша дорога Німеччини.
Друзі, виявилося, що найгірша дорога в Німеччині
з тих, що я бачив, веде до школи пілотів і аеродрому,
де стоять приватні літаки.
Тож якщо купуватиме потримане авто з Німеччини,
дізнайтеся, якими дорогами вона їздила. До речі,
чим не нова тема: будівництво та ремонт доріг у Німеччині?
Шановні глядачі відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину",
пишіть, що ще вас цікавить у ФРН, і я обов'язково
про це розкажу в одній з наступних серій. Побачимося!